the loo the water closet the John or the
toilet
it has many names but one function
transporting biological waste and other
unwanted things from your house to the
public sewer system quick TSA don't
flush moist towelettes or baby wipes
down the toilet they don't dissolve in
water and make fatbergs which are
disgusting and clog our sewers despite
the fact that the toilet has one use
this question still comes up for reasons
I do not know can you drink toilet water
No
yes it's clear it's wet and it's water
but that doesn't mean you can drink it
in doing my research for this video I
found a decent amount of inquisitive
people really wanting to know if you can
drink toilet water and others who
believe it's completely harmless let's
take a gander at a few of these shall we
is toilet water bad for you answer
toilet water can be extremely harmful to
your health and should only be consumed
in the case of extreme emergency what
kind of emergency are you talking about
there bud like you're in the middle of
the Sahara Desert with no water in your
only source is a public toilet and
grading seems on point when I flush a
toilet is the new water that fills up
the bowl drinkable assuming it's tap
water if not why not
or how many flushes will it take what do
you mean how many flushes will it take
and why are you even asking this
question in the first place is toilet
water is clean as tap water I know that
the toilet bowl itself is filled with
bacteria and once the water is in the
bowl it's not safe to drink but is the
water it comes from just as clean as the
tap technically speaking could someone
drink water from the toilet if you had a
100% new and clean toilet yes
moving on why is it safe for humans to
drink from the toilet but not my pets
what my daughter drained toilet water I
was cleaning our room and heard
splashing walked into the adjoining
bathroom to find dear daughter scooping
water out of the toilet bowl with her
hands and putting them in her mouth I'm
so grossed out I clean the toilet a few
days ago but it's been used since then
it's a source of fresh water as long as
there wasn't any urine her feces in it
at the time or chemicals in it she's
fine my cats drink out a toilet upstairs
because their water is downstairs
our old dog
only drank out of the toilets it's not
dirty unless there's something in it
making it dirty really it's not dirty
unless there's something in it making it
dirty
what do you think goes into that toilet
bowl milk and Cheerios now these people
could be trolls or they could be
genuinely ignorant about drinking toilet
water it could be because they see their
pets doing it and monkey-see monkey-do
think it's probably safe at least for me
I've never looked at the food my dog was
eating and was like oh yeah give me some
of that dry processed dog food with
questionable ingredients at any rate if
you're curious about drinking out of
your toilet because your dog does it
don't dogs are known to eat their own
feces and a variety of other bacteria
saturated things like raw meat dogs can
do this because they evolved as
opportunistic scavengers eating fresh
meat or several day old meat they have
enzymes they're released immediately in
their stomach and food passes through
their body much faster preventing them
from getting sick from bacteria us
humans have a much different in slower
digestive system so don't do it
for those of you who are still really
interested in drinking toilet water I
did you the favor of growing a bacterial
culture from the toilet I took three
different bacterial swabs one from the
toilet bowl one from the tank and one
from the tap here's the results in case
you didn't believe me now you can see
for yourself the toilet bowl is full of
bacteria okay
so you can't freakin drink it when you
flush yes all the wastes visibly goes
down the drain into the sewer system but
there's still residual microscopic
bacteria left over just how much is left
over well through analysis of 11
different studies where bacterial cells
were counted in human stool there was on
average 90 billion bacterial cells per
gram of feces with about 50% of those
bacteria being alive the average weight
of human stool per bowel movement is
about 226 grams or the same weight as an
8 ounce sirloin 226 grams times 90
billion bacteria per gram with about 50%
being alive comes to about 10 trillion
living bacterial cells per bowel
movement even with the flush carrying
the waste away there's likely millions
if not hundreds and millions of bacteria
still in the bowl again just look at the
petri dish but what happens if
you don't heed my warning and you still
drink the toilet water well there's two
different scenarios that can go down the
first scenario is pretty benign
basically you get food poisoning and
that's it
your body tries to get rid of the
bacteria in your GI tract by fever
vomiting and diarrhea this is usually
self resolving in two to three days with
fluids and proper treatment and is not
life-threatening
the second scenario Shuchi and is far
far worse than food poisoning sepsis is
a massive systemic inflammatory immune
response caused by the normally high
bacterial infection in your blood known
as blood poisoning blood poisoning is
severe and often fatal this is because
your blood is your life force it flows
throughout your entire body carrying
oxygen and nutrients to all your organs
having pathogenic bacteria floating
around in your blood to all your organs
is pretty much worst-case scenario in
blood poisoning blood pH is wildly
thrown off pathogenic proteins are
released throughout your body and cells
are dying from bacterial infection
naturally your body freaks out it
overreacts by producing an
overcompensating immune response
resulting in a cytokine storm cytokines
act as signaling molecules to alert
cells for example when a pathogen like a
virus is in the body cytokines are
released and bind to cells to tell them
that a pathogen is nearby these cells
then initiate the production of immune
cells and inflammation reactions to
remove the pathogen the system works
great with sepsis it's not just a few
pathogens but many many pathogens and
their widespread to counteract this the
body releases many many cytokines when
an abnormally high amount of cytokines
are released the immune system goes into
a dangerous positive feedback loop the
high number of cytokine signal a large
amount of cells to induce an immune
response the heightened immune response
creates inflammation causing the release
of more cytokines which then signal more
immune cells this cycle continues
getting increasingly chaotic this is
known as a cytokine storm and the
response is akin to removing termites by
burning down your house
sepsis and the following cytokine storm
result in septic shock causing rapid
heart rate drop in blood pressure and
organ failure which typically results in
a fatality sadly this very scenario
happened to an 8 year old girl named
Raley browning in the UK her parents and
aunt prevented her from drinking water
over a three-day period being severely
dehydrated she took to drinking water
from a toilet causing her to go into
fatal septic shock and in case you're
wondering yes all three are in prison
however drinking toilet water doesn't
always mean that you'll go into septic
shock in 2017 a Tennessee State
University student billed her roommates
water bottle with toilet water the
roommate showed signs of weight loss and
stomach issues but did not have any
serious injury or sepsis so what
determines whether drinking from the
porcelain throne will give you food
poisoning or septic shock if you're
immunocompromised or elderly you've
pretty much sealed your fate if you're
young and healthy the one factor that
will determine expiration or
regurgitation is the type of bacteria in
the toilet bowl some bacteria are more
deadly than others it depends what
bacteria the person had in their colon
when they use the toilet for example if
you drink water contaminated with
lactobacillus you'd most likely get food
poisoning but if you drink water with
e.coli h pylori Vibrio Salmonella or
Clostridium you're in trouble
these are notoriously pathogenic
organisms that cause serious diseases a
large concentration of these in your
water would certainly cause sepsis for
example many of these bacteria have
pathogenic molecules called endotoxins
which are found in gram-negative
bacteria by the way all the
gram-negative means is that these type
of bacteria don't retain a colored stain
in their cell membrane that's all
endotoxins are one of the major factors
that cause septic shock in an individual
this is due to the fact that these
toxins are potent stimulators of the
immune system increasing the likeliness
of a cytokine storm and subsequently
septic shock endotoxins are so potent
that they can cause an immune response
at picogram per milliliter quantities
translation it's so potent it's
effective at concentrations of one part
per trillion however there is some irony
to these toxins endotoxins are only
released in the
when immune cells attacked bacteria for
example the bacterium ecoli carries an
endo toxin called lipid a in its outer
membrane when attached to the bacterial
cell
the endotoxin carries little threat to
the body once immune cells lyse the
e.coli lipid a is freed from the
membrane and released into the
circulation at large quantities immune
cells then come in contact with this
endotoxin and begin to ramp up the
immune response which is where the
cytokine storm enters the scene alas if
you did end up drinking toilet water
even though you were told not to and
have gone full septic there is still a
glimmer of hope
hospitals have developed a surprisingly
specific and effective protocol in
treating sepsis due to the fact that
sepsis is an incredibly fatal
circumstance because again you have
bacteria releasing toxins in your blood
that make your immune system go the
standard protocol is pretty beefed up
firstly patients are given antibiotics
within the first hour of being diagnosed
which helps to reduce the bacterial
presence in the blood low blood pressure
is treated with vasopressors like
norepinephrine and are given to increase
the patient's blood pressure the patient
has also given a blood transfusion as
well finally the rapid production of
cytokines have to be stopped
surprisingly this is done by giving the
patient anesthetics certain inhaled
anesthetics have been shown to reduce
the production of cytokines thereby
slowing down the immune response it's
incredibly important for someone with
sepsis to receive treatment within the
first three hours of being diagnosed
every hour that the person is not
treated there is a 6% increase in
mortality so remember
despite your own curiosity or what other
people say don't drink toilet water ever
you